[Música]
la justicia rusa expidió una resolución
para prohibir las actividades de la
compañía tecnológica meta dueña de las
redes sociales facebook instagram y
whatsapp a quien acusa de extremista por
permitir comentarios violentos de
usuarios en contra de rusia
en cuba los habitantes de la isla han
salido a las estaciones de servicio para
evitar quedar inmovilizados por la falta
de combustible al problema del
suministro de gasolina se suma al de
alimentos y medicamentos
en guatemala la jueza anticorrupción
erika ayfán renunció a la corte suprema
de justicia y sopesa su exilio en eeuu
la jueza tenía testimonios de
financiación ilegal de campaña contra el
presidente alejandro giammattei
ampliamos desde guatemala
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos este noticiero
hablando de redes sociales en el
conflicto entre rusia y ucrania porque
la justicia rusa expidió una resolución
para prohibir en su territorio las
actividades de la compañía tecnológica
meta dueña de las redes sociales
facebook instagram y whatsapp la
justicia del país considera a la empresa
como extremista por permitir comentarios
violentos de usuarios en contra de rusia
para analizar esta decisión previamente
hablamos con mauricio jaramillo marín
director y cofundador en impacto tics
que nos habló sobre el uso de estas
plataformas como elemento
propagandístico y sobre la censura
durante esta guerra
es mucho más drástico pero si vamos un
poquito de la historia hace 15 días más
o menos la unión europea exigió que se
desmontarán por ejemplo
rt de google entonces en europa cuando
alguien busca el medio de comunicación
de ruso no va a encontrar rt ni sus
contenidos entonces es algo que viene de
un lado del otro pero obviamente rusia
al desmontar facebook y al desmontar
instagram y decir que me está está
promoviendo el extremismo
claramente se va a un extremo justamente
en esto de tomar algo de censura o mucho
de censura y de limitar la información
libre a través de internet
consecuencia de la guerra es el
encarecimiento de la escasez de
combustible en cuba también se vive esta
carencia por lo que los habitantes de la
isla han salido a las estaciones de
servicio para evitar quedar
inmovilizados al problema del suministro
de gasolina se suma al de alimentos y
medicamentos no sólo por el bloqueo
estadounidense sino por la falta de
efectivo en la isla debido a la baja de
turistas andrés granadillo nos cuenta
más
filas por temor a la escasez en las
gasolineras de cuba decenas de personas
esperan para poder llenar sus tanques de
combustible el problema de la gasolina
es terrible esto está bien a las siete y
media la mañana va por poco a sonriendo
cuantos seguir trabajando nuevo y en
toda la situación que cada cinco minutos
sucede los mismos los mismos lo mismo no
resolvamos los problemas hermanos les
pasamos todos los medios de comunicación
informaron de un posible racionamiento
debido a la crisis económica en la que
está sumida la isla donde ya hay escasez
de alimentos y medicinas según las
autoridades las causas de la falta de
suministros se debe a problemas de
distribución y de logística los
funcionarios en cuba culpan al embargo
estadounidense de décadas ya las
sanciones más recientes y severas bajo
el ex presidente estadounidense donald
trump aunque los expertos creen que son
otras las causas
dominación de la escasez de producto y
de crudo provenientes de venezuela
también tenemos que reconocer que cuba
ahora tiene más dificultad en ir a los
mercados y mercados internacionales
y comprar
gasolina o diésel ya que los precios han
aumentado en un 40% en los últimos meses
como resultado de la guerra de ucrania
además la isla ha luchado en la pandemia
por recuperar el turismo clave para la
entrada de divisas con las que compra
alimentos combustible medicamentos y
materias primas pero los turistas aún no
vuelven y vamos a guatemala donde la
jueza anticorrupción eric ayfán renunció
a la corte suprema de justicia y sopesa
su exilio en eeuu la jueza tenía en su
despacho el testimonio de un testigo que
acusa al presidente alejandro giammatei
de haber financiado su campaña electoral
con 2,6 millones de dólares provenientes
de sobornos nuestro corresponsal en
guatemala' andrés suárez jaramillo tiene
los detalles
el pasado 9 de marzo erika ayfán la jefa
del tribunal de mayor riesgo de
guatemala debió abandonar el país por
tierra hacia el salvador cruzo luego a
costa rica y desde allí voló hacia eeuu
sólo 12 días después sus abogados
hicieron pública su renuncia ante la
corte suprema de justicia el mismo día
en que ella denunció en twitter las
amenazas en contra de su vida y de su
integridad por parte de estructuras de
corrupción del estado guatemalteco así
como redes de criminalidad y es que el
cerco contra la magistrada ayfán se
estrechó a mediados del pasado febrero
cuando se supo que en su despacho
guardaba el testimonio de un ex hombre
de confianza del actual presidente
alejandro giammatei quien lo acusa de
haber recibido en corrupción 26 millones
de dólares para presuntamente haber
financiado su campaña electoral
desde entonces la fiscal general ha
emitido siete ante juicios en contra de
la magistrada ayfán que le
representarían perder su inmunidad y
entrar a la cárcel con ayfán son 15 los
funcionarios
si es que en su lucha en contra de la
impunidad en guatemala han tenido que
abandonar el país en el último año en
eeuu empezaron las audiencias ante el
comité judicial del país para decidir
sobre quién ocupará el máximo puesto de
la corte suprema de justicia en estos
días se decidirá si la candidata
demócrata que está allí brawn jackson se
convierte en la primera afroamericana en
ocupar ese lugar
podría convertirse en la primera
afroamericana en ocupar el puesto más
alto de la justicia estadounidense
antonio y brawn jackson brindó su
discurso frente al senado en fort
benning
pero gracias por convocar esta audiencia
y por considerar mi nominación a la
corte suprema de los estados unidos me
siento honrada de estar aquí
ambos en alerta civil en febrero el
presidente joe biden y su historia
postulando el mandatario demócrata
durante su campaña prometió diversificar
el tribunal que durante dos siglos
estuvo conformado por hombres blancos
los senadores compartieron sus elogios y
preocupaciones mons
sólo ha habido 115 jueces en la historia
de nuestra nación la nominación de la
jueza jackson por supuesto es histórica
lo que me preocupa y soy muy sincero
es que en todos los casos en cada uno de
estos 7 la jueza jackson dictó una
sentencia indulgente que estaba por
debajo de lo que recomendaban las normas
federales y los fiscales jackson de 53
años fue nombrada miembro del tribunal
federal por el entonces presidente obama
en el 2013 su nombre fue noticia también
en el año 2019 cuando ordenó al ex
abogado de la casa blanca durante la
presidencia del trump testificar ante el
comité judicial de la cámara sobre si
trump había obstruido la investigación
del ex fiscal bühler sobre la
interferencia rusa en las elecciones del
2016 las audiencias durarán cuatro días
y allí se decidirá si eeuu las historias
reivindicando a una minoría del país
como son los afroamericanos que han
venido históricamente denunciando las
vulneraciones de sus derechos
cerramos con la crisis climática
naciones unidas advirtió una vez más
sobre la urgencia de aplicar medidas
concretas para alcanzar la neutralidad
climática en 2050 responsable
responsabilidad que recae especialmente
en las potencias más ricas que son las
más contaminantes del mundo
el mensaje es claro si las potencias
mundiales no aplican medidas claras para
frenar la crisis climática en los
próximos dos años los planes para
acercarse a la neutralidad climática en
2050 podrían ser irrelevantes así lo
expresó el equipo especial de naciones
unidas para la crisis climática
cálix tus amigos decir que la humanidad
se encuentra en una encrucijada es un
eufemismo la década de 2020 debe ser la
década de las acciones
y es que según los expertos el mundo
está muy lejos del objetivo del
calentamiento un máximo de 15 grados
celsius para 2050 una de las principales
razones es la insuficiente reducción de
los combustibles fósiles el mayor
impulsor de la crisis climática
provocado por el hombre ya que a pesar
de que casi 200 países se comprometieron
a reducir el uso de estos combustibles
en el pacto de glasgow en 2021 algunos
como australia no están llevando a cabo
agua objective
nuestros objetivos fueron acordados por
todas las partes a la luz de las pruebas
científicas para conseguirlo necesitamos
contribuciones determinadas a nivel
nacional más ambiciosas
en medio de esta crisis mundial las
naciones en desarrollo exigen a los
países más ricos pagar un precio más
elevado y ayudarlos en la transición
climática ya que las potencias del g20
representan más del 80 por ciento de las
emisiones del mundo
la promesa de los 100 mil millones de
dólares era un compromiso firme que aún
no se ha cumplido y se debe hacer
realidad ese 2022 en tuenti tu actitud
medidas que se deben aplicar en lo que
los expertos denominan como el tiempo de
descuento para nuestro planeta hasta
aquí este informativo sigan conectados a
france 24
[Música]